(light ambient music)
- Hi, I'm Linda, I'm otherwise known
as SaltySeattle, and I am a pasta artist.
I share most of my pasta
creations on Instagram
because Instagram is such a perfect medium
for really visually arresting
and delicious things.
Today we're making all of the colors
for rainbow pappardelle,
and you go through
the entire color of the rainbow.
And it's not arbitrary,
we continue to build on each new color.
The first color of pasta dough
I'm going to make is blue.
I use a special flower called
the butterfly pea flower,
and it grows on a vine
and it's bright blue,
and it's native to southeast Asia.
To make purple pasta dough
I love to use a mixture
of dragonfruit and
blueberry, and I like to use
double zero pasta flour
because the texture is supple,
and it has a very low gluten
slash protein content.
For the next pasta dough
color, it'll be red.
And so I like to mix
together beets and harissa.
And beets by themselves are really pink,
and so you add the harissa
in there to sort of offset
that pinkness and give it a
little bit more of a true red.
Today I'm using harissa to
achieve my orange pasta dough,
but you could also use
paprika to achieve this color.
I use turmeric to make
the yellow pasta dough,
and I love to use the whole
tumeric root rather than the powder.
For the last pasta dough I'm
gonna go with bright green,
and in order to achieve that bright green,
I use parsley, and I
like to mix just a tiny
little bit of tumeric with it.
So to make the rainbow we're
gonna do rainbow stripes
and use this cutter for the pasta machine
called a fettuccine
cutter to make our strips
of different colors of pasta dough.
Now we have our stripes
placed on our base sheet,
and we're gonna run it back
through the pasta machine.
If you don't have a pasta
machine and you want
to make pasta anyway,
just use a rolling pin.
The cool thing about pasta
dough is you can re-roll it
and re-roll it, and
you're not gonna hurt it
as long as it doesn't dry out too much.
I think I really honed my
pasta making skill, though,
living in Italy and just
learning from grandmas
and learning their specific
noodle that they were
really passionate about.
(classical instrumental music)
I'm making caramelle pasta,
and I'm using this really
gorgeous magenta dough and combining it
with a yellow, a bright tumeric
sunny yolk color yellow.
These tools that I'm using
right now are actually
probably more common for
cake and cookie decorating.
I always have pasta on
my mind and I'm always
thinking about tools that I could
potentially repurpose and use for pasta.
The filling is made of ricotta
cheese and some nutmeg,
salt, and a little bit of sugar.
Caramelle means candies in
Italian, which you probably
could have guessed just
by looking at their shape.
(classical music)
Pasta is a course, and
you do not serve anything
with the pasta, it should
be loved and appreciated
and admired for itself as a course.
The pasta shape we're making
now is called garganelli.
They have ridges on them which
sauce just loves to cling to.
This is a pasta bike.
You can cut squares and
rectangles with this thing.
If you want to serve it with something
that's really hearty and substantial,
then a thicker pasta could
really stand up to that.
Really I would say that thinness
is a matter of personal preference.
I always grew up wanting to do art
and it probably ultimately
came down to finding
the right medium, and it
just feels right in my hands.
(light classical music)